Peter Brown here with a gamespot news
update if you love your playstation 3
don't worry sony says they're going to
continue support it as long as there's
business there thanks Tony of course
Sony is going to be focusing the bulk of
their support on their new flagship the
PlayStation 4 but PlayStation America
exact Scott rody says people are still
buying PlayStation 3's all the different
parts of the world just adopt new
technology at different rates we don't
know where all this is going but we will
continue to support the PlayStation 3
through first and third parties as long
as there's good business there for us
third-party publishers still recognize
the potential of last gen systems as
well there are a handful of games still
coming to the PlayStation 3 this year
including heavy hitters like Call of
Duty advanced warfare far cry 4 dragon
age inquisition and destiny Sony is
bringing a little big planet 3 to the
PlayStation 3 this fall as well the xbox
360 hasn't been abandoned either
Microsoft has said they plan to support
the 360 for at least another three years
but if you're ready to upgrade to
next-gen consoles and you want to get
rid of your PlayStation through your
xbox 360 for an xbox one take them to
gamestop today or saturday for an extra
fifty percent credit back on your
trade-in stay tuned to gamespot com for
more video game news